hey guys I'm Alexa Medina and this is
hashtag reality hi today we're gonna
talk about my ninety million followers
can't believe you watch that my name is
Alexa mattina and I'm a huge [ __ ] yes
Alexa you're in my shot
the truth is I'm just a goofy dog-loving
nerd good grades are hilarious I don't
think that that is what they're laughing
at found him wandering the halls
sniffing this magic marker this is an
outrage and I deny all charges you have
two friends Freddie and grandma grandma
is dead you need to get some friends
okay hey I'm having a party Saturday you
around
you should come I think I could probably
oh yeah oh yeah I think I could swing
that mm-hmm
this is a bad idea you don't have the
best track record with these people I
did tell you this is a pool party right
oh my god I can see what camera likes
you know you're shopping with us
tomorrow I am one second I was in Malibu
in the next I was too freaking cute eggs
party you know like BFS now I'm gonna
change my life have fun with your new
fake friends why can't you just be happy
for me
hey guys today we're gonna talk about
Dani burns she's a stalker you thought I
was just gonna let her steal my
boyfriend you've been losing yourself
Freddie you're my best friend
I'm sorry I was a jerk to you a way
bigger jerk I lost myself just to get
likes from a bunch of people that I
don't even like no offense you know you
the first person I have about here are
less special you are
[Applause]
you